Hey, here's a funny voicemail we hear often
from a guy I know as the San Antonio troll.
One of the traits of the San Antonio troll
is that he calls in and criticizes me for
positions I haven't taken and often criticizes
my coverage of stories I haven't even talked
about.
And here, listen to what he says about my
view on reparations, which he clearly has
never heard or doesn't understand.
Take a listen.
Mm.
Yeah.
So your uh, interview with the good old, same
here, right?
Willing to bet you didn't plan this because
he's my stateness is too good.
Two things.
First off, I'm willing that you sit there
on your little, any little ivory tower, oh
light.
The white man needs to pay reparations, blah,
blah, blah.
I've never said it, but I'm willing to bet
if you had to pay some of those reparations,
we'll take 30, 40% of your patients who would
take it a guess.
They ran my main points.
It's pretty sad that you far leftist constantly
preach black power, black people, you know,
this and that.
There's so great, Yada, Yada, Yada.
Yet here you guys are seeing that black people
can't make it without white people's money.
I think it's very sad.
Um, and I think it's racist.
This is the best.
I've never said anything even related black
power.
This is a program that [inaudible] previous
black power who even makes cases around reparations
on the basis of whether black people are quotes.
So great.
So once again, someone criticizing me for
a position I've never taken and things that
I've never said.
As I've said before, as I said when I spoke
to Sam Harris, as I've said, when people call
in and ask me about reparations, I'm open
to the idea of reparations.
I have a number of questions about the logistics
of how it would work.
I have a number of questions about who it
is that would receive them and I'm willing
to be convinced of exactly how it would all
work.
But I have said that I believe strategically
in terms of the 2020 presidential campaign,
it is a mistake to focus on reparations.
And that is my position.
So criticize that San Antonio troll rather
than whatever Cockamamie, uh, position you
are inherently implicitly suggesting I've
taken because I just haven't, and I'm wondering
if you even heard my interview with Tim Harris.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant [inaudible] an
access to the bonus show by signing up@joinpacmandotcomorbecomingapatronathatreddotcomslashdaviddavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.